Edie its Ross always great to talk with
you I'm filling in for Dan today really
appreciate the time can you just kind of
lay out the scene and exactly what
happened as you know it yeah Ross here's
what happened on Wednesday morning in a
walkthrough
Antonia blew up at Ben it was brief it
wasn't long but he was ticked off at
something so the two talked on Thursday
morning and they aren't things out I
mean Ben said he was fine Antoni was
fine now we don't know what set him off
from there but later on Thursday before
practice on Thursday these dealers
elected the players elected their MVP as
they've been doing for 50 years one of
the few teams that does this and the
elected
JooJoo Smith Shuster and then that's
when Antonio skipped practice Thursday
he was given off Wednesday by the coach
and that's not unusual Ben doesn't
practice Wednesday a lot of you know a
lot of the vets he gets off on
Wednesdays so he blew off Thursday's
practice blew off Friday's practice did
not show up Saturday for the walkthrough
or the team meetings later and then came
to the showed up at the game on Sunday
morning expecting apply and Mike made
him inactive there you go in an
important what could have been a vital
game for them you know had had Cleveland
pulled that off in Baltimore the
Steelers would be in a playoffs but had
they lost as a Antonio Brown didn't show
up that would have been that would have
been a scandal I think oh my gosh if
they had lost that game and the Ravens
lost and they would have made the
playoffs that would have been insane I
guess my question ed is how many other
things with him Antonio Brown have
happened to the point where he thought
he could just show up on Sunday and
still play in the game I mean it's just
like a common thing for him skipping
stuff no it really isn't he used to be
their hardest worker
there's something going on I don't know
what it is something happening this
here you know he's flipped out on any
number of occasions this was the most
serious one football-wise
but you know he was accused of throwing
stuff off a balcony in Florida there's a
lawsuit involved there where he almost
allegedly almost hit the guy and his kid
he he was ticketed for going 110 miles
an hour on a busy McKnight Road in
suburban Pittsburgh he got into a
sideline confrontation with the
offensive coordinator one game and then
blew off the Monday meetings and Tomlin
said he disciplined him for that didn't
say what the discipline was there's been
all kinds of stuff blew up at me for
nothing during training camp but
verbally attacked me threatened another
reporter from ESPN physically in a tweet
it's just it's it's been snowballing
Ross it really has well that's
unfortunate
I will tell you ed and we're talking
about that bruschetta the Pittsburgh
post-gazette
who's at the Steelers facility and my
experienced head
I think the juju Smith Shuster MVP thing
it was a big deal because you know hell
hath no fury like a scorned wide
receiver because they know they need to
get the ball there is depend there's
anybody on the ball and especially when
it's like a long time number one wide
receiver and they kind of feel like that
status is threatened I've seen that
happen a number of times I I don't think
that's a coincidence at all ready yeah I
agree with you Ross and I even suggested
that they do away with that thing it
it's Morris light to others than it is a
you know an honor for the MVP you're
sliding others pen was slighted Ben
should have been our MVP in fact they'd
a name if they'd elected Penn this
probably wouldn't happen because you can
kick a Antonio could have understood the
quarterback but order you know one of
the reasons you get so many balls is
because they double-team Antonio problem
doesn't it feel like a you know like for
them to not vote Roethlisberger the envy
it almost feels like a popularity
contest yeah it is
he's one of only one through 15 years
Ross you know a lot of people say oh
they could name the quarterback every
year well they name them you know when
he leads the league in passing yards
yeah unbelievable we're talking with
that boot shed
Edie at noon today I know you're at the
Steelers facility noon Eastern Mike Tom
was going to address the media what what
do you think he's gonna say Mike's too
smart to to allow anything controversial
to come out I think and what I mean by
that is he put on the he put on the
injury list of a Antonio Brown all week
coach's decision slash knee injury and
he said he had some discomfort so I
think he's just gonna double down on
that say hey it wasn't me
you know that's why you didn't practice
you know he had discomfort in the knee
and that kind of you know there's not
gonna be any gotcha there so ed when you
say to him but what about Mike the three
days off and multiple sources telling me
that he didn't show up til the game on
say like what's he gonna say to that I
don't know him blowing off Saturday you
know even if even if you have a knee
injury you show up at the team meetings
right he wasn't even he didn't even he
didn't rehab it he didn't have any
medical attention that's one thing Mike
said he he went for medical tests it's
our understanding he didn't and there's
no chance with the dead money that he'd
actually be traded right I mean it'd be
like twenty one point five million
hitting the cat there's no way that's
gonna happen correct
raus I just wrote this for my paper I
don't know if it's online yet or not
it's 22 million if he plays this year
that's his hit 21 million if they trade
them so the hit is the same basically
however you're not paying on the 12 and
a half million salary or the two and a
half million roster bonus these do March
18th so there's a there's what's that 15
million off that 21 you could do a lot
with that 15 million plus you see Iran
talking on up you're not on a books form
after this year if you truly believe
he's a poison I think you trade them
come on get some other wide receivers
free agency draft however you want to
trade however you want to do it sounds
like the money they saved from not
having to pay lady on bail any money I
mean honestly add between the Le'Veon
Bell stuff the Antonio Brown stuff been
calling out some teammates publicly you
can't tell me that that hasn't had some
impact on this team underachieving right
right
no there's a little doubt I mean lady on
bail would have helped them this year's
no doubt him and Connor would have been
a nice team at the very least if they
you know if Connor if they went with
Connor and bail reported later when
Connor got hurt they could plug bail
right in there yeah you lose great
players you ever heard yourself but the
Bell things done you know that move on
from him gonna need another running back
to and can't just go with Connor and
then this rookie you got to find another
one so if if they move Antonio and I
talked to one personnel guys I don't
know how how we can't get rid of them
you know how do you how do you live with
that
people say well sit down and talk to him
they've done that for years
the man's 30 years old he's not gonna
change wow sounds like you think it
might happen it well I think it's
possible I don't know you know I thought
they shouldn't attack Pell last year no
they didn't listen to me they're you
know Lee they do what they do they don't
panic that's one thing they don't do
Ross
you know one thing you have to do is you
got to think without Antonio who you
callin to juju and I guess I mean you
have to find somebody else and James
Washington who they drafted last year
started coming on a little late this
year
you know the day still think they have a
Super Bowl team but I don't I don't know
how you live with this and always
appreciate the time really curious to
see what Mike Tomlin ends up saying we
all are today yeah I bet thanks dad
there is Ed bruschetta of the Pittsburgh
post-gazette for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]